what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and tonight I get to see Guardians of
the Galaxy I get to attend the world
premiere thanks Marvel and Disney as
always and I'm really excited for this
one the people who have already seen it
in Europe are raving about it some say
it's the best Guardians of the Galaxy
film yet and the entire franchise so I'm
really excited about it if you want to
catch some picks from the event I'll be
posting them to the cosmic Wonder
Instagram and my personal Instagram as
well but since I see the film tonight I
wanted to talk about the post credit
scenes James Gunn has confirmed that
there are indeed going to be two
post-credit scenes and since I can't
really say anything after I see it I
want to talk about what I think that
we're going to see in these two
post-credit scenes I think we're going
to get setups for the Fantastic Four I
think we're going to get setups for Nova
also big thank you to everybody who said
that the studio is looking really good
lately I super appreciate it I could not
have done it without my partners over at
Elgato they provide all of the lighting
that you can control on your phone or
with one of their products and the
microphone I use every single day is
from Elgato so if you're looking for
some awesome gear be sure to check it
out in the link in the description down
below now since there are two you have
to imagine that Marvel Studios is
definitely going to want something
teasing some upcoming movie or project
or the big bad Kang the Conqueror
however since recently there have been a
lot of allegations against Jonathan
majors of course most people know he was
arrested and despite him and his lawyer
claiming that Jonathan Majors is 100
innocent as actually a victim in this
situation and they say that they have
evidence and we have seen some photos
but despite all that Disney and Marvel
might be wanting to steer clear of that
just for now but the Guardians of the
Galaxy has the opportunity to perfectly
set up Nova and or the Fantastic Four
and I remember there were rumors going
around a while ago when they first
started shooting for the Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 that the Silver Surfer
could appear in the movie now James Gunn
has recently debunked this he loves to
do that and typically he is always is
told the truth however I'm guessing that
if the Silver Surfer was in the film he
wouldn't say anything that is way too
big of a cameo to even think about
however if he was in the movie I'm sure
he would just be quiet he wouldn't reply
to somebody stating no he's not in the
movie however that doesn't mean he's not
in the post-credits scene most people
consider the movie in the post-credit
scenes separate things they are
different events usually especially with
Marvel so the Silver Surfer could very
well be in a post-credits scene for
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 especially
if you consider the fact that the
Fantastic Four movie is right around the
corner and we've heard a lot of talks
that the Silver Surfer and Galactus are
going to be the main villains of the
Fantastic Four film mind you this isn't
100 confirmed but this is what some
insiders are stating we've also heard
that there is a Silver Surfer special
presentation in the works currently at
Marvel Studios also a Nova special
presentation which we'll talk about in
just a bit now even with all of the
Jonathan major stuff going on right now
they're still going to have Kang as the
big bad if everything that Jonathan
majors and his lawyer saying is true
then he is still going to be king and if
not well Marvel will simply recast him
but no matter what Kang is still the big
bad of the MCU after all we are getting
Avengers the Kang Dynasty and Secret
Wars is going to be about defeating Kang
and all of his variants as well so I am
assuming that one of these post-credits
scenes is going to be about Kang whether
it's another look at what is to come in
Loki season 2 whether it's look at Kang
doing something completely different
that we have no idea about maybe in our
universe maybe in a different Universe
whatever it may be I'm thinking we are
getting a tease for Kang and one of
these post-credit scenes because that
just makes sense but the second
post-credits scene I legitimately think
could be about Nova the first Guardians
of the Galaxy film really explored
zandar and the Nova core the connection
is already there but here's the thing
here's why I really think a Nova setup
would be perfect as sad as it sounds
this is the end of the Guardians of the
Galaxy at least for this specific team
many of the actors are going to move on
whether that's because their characters
have died or they're simply done with
the trilogy just like James Gunn however
we do know that there is going to be a
new Guardians of the Galaxy team formed
eventually in the MCU that could be
right away or it could take five years
we're not really sure but we know that
it's the end of this specific team and
not the Guardians team in general in the
MCU so that makes us ask the question
well who is going to be in the new
Guardians of the Galaxy team and I'm
thinking Nova is the perfect character
to be a part of the Guardians of the
Galaxy and if he is going to be a part
of the team this is pretty much the
perfect opportunity to tease that to
give us a little bit of hope that the
new Guardians of the Galaxy team isn't
that far away from being formed and
again as far as new members of the
Guardians of the Galaxy team we don't
know who the new team is going to
consist of but Nova just makes sense he
would be perfect and this would be the
perfect opportunity to set him up and
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is the
first guardian's film after Avengers
endgame and infinity war and it was an
Infinity War where the Guardians learned
that xandar was decimated so maybe
they'll go visit zandar in the film just
to kind of see what happened and try to
help whoever they can maybe they'll meet
Nova there we'll have to wait and see on
that one but like I said there have been
reports from insiders that a Silver
Surfer special presentation is also
coming the report is that this is going
to come before the Fantastic Four movie
because the Silver Surfer and Galactus
are going to be in the Fantastic Four so
really a tease for the Silver Surfer
would essentially be a tease for the
upcoming Fantastic Four movie and since
we don't know who the official cast is
yet there's no way they're going to kind
of tease the Fantastic Four because
they're not going to show us who the
cast is they're not just going to give
us a post-credit scene with Reed and Sue
and show us who they are I think it
would be really cool if they did it that
way but that's typically not how Marvel
does it so if you're gonna tease the
Fantastic Four it would be really cool
to get a Silver Surfer and maybe even a
Galactus tease even though getting a
Silver Surfer tease is essentially
getting a Galactus tease because he's
his Herald but keep in mind we know from
the Guardians of the Galaxy a holiday
special that the Guardians are now in
charge of nowhere they bought it it's
theirs they are the true Guardians of
the Galaxy now trying to protect the
Galaxy as an official team so if a
Herald of Galactus was making its way
towards Earth I'm assuming that people
from nowhere would either pick up on it
or spot the surfer himself and I think
that it would be a really killer
post-credits scene if they just kind of
showed the Silver Surfer off in the
background and we see some of the
remaining guardians or new characters
say what is that and then it gets really
serious and some people say oh crap
that's a Herald for Galactus that's all
we need you don't even have to cast the
Silver Surfer yet you just have to have
kind of a basic silhouette of the Silver
Surfer riding his board in the
background in the cosmos which is where
Guardians of the Galaxy is going to take
place or if the Silver Surfer has
possibly been cast already you can have
him show up at nowhere maybe he goes
there to investigate if this head is
going to be enough energy for Galactus
he could stop by nowhere determine that
nowhere isn't suitable for Galactus and
then kind of hint that he's heading to
Earth and obviously if some of the
original Guardians members are sticking
around for the next team if they're
there at nowhere they're going to have a
connection to Earth because of infinity
war and end game well really just end
game for the guardians but they fought
to save Earth in the entire universe so
they're obviously going to be concerned
that a Herald of Galactus is going to
Earth so really I think this would be a
Kind of Perfect opportunity to tease the
Silver Surfer in Galactus for the
upcoming Fantastic Four film at least of
course this is what I hope for now there
is always the possibility that the
post-credits scene is going to be some
kind of tribute to our Guardians of the
Galaxy this is their last film maybe
it's some sort of a tribute to the cast
this isn't something that that Marvel
typically does however if James Gunn
kind of wanted to say in what the
post-credits scene could be well there
is always the possibility that it could
be this however typically Marvel does
like to set up the future they did this
with Thanos and it would make sense that
they would do it with Kang and More
Heroes and more villains like Nova the
Silver Surfer and Galactus but we'll
have to wait and see I watched the movie
tonight I'll film a reaction right after
and post it to YouTube and the next day
Friday tomorrow morning I'll be posting
my review of IT spoiler free of course
but keep an eye out for that make sure
you subscribe and hit the notification
Bell so you don't miss those videos
don't forget to like the video and of
course you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof